[Musique]
bonsoir anthony arafat on va
s'intéresser au mali on va revenir sur
l'opération militaire menée amoureux
c'était à la fin du mois de mars
opération particulièrement sanglante à
huy est particulièrement sujette aussi à
polémique on va voir pourquoi on va
rappeler justement de mots de contexte
nous sommes le 23 mars dernier dans la
région de morat on va voir la carte pour
savoir où ça se situe c'est au niveau du
point rouge l'armée malienne lance une
opération elle assure avoir neutralisé
plus de 200 terroristes un bilan que
contexte human rights watch ong qui
affirme que dans cette action menée
conjointement on le rappelle avec des
membres présumés du groupe russe wagner
plus de 300 civils auraient été tués et
c'est d'ailleurs cela qui a poussé la
justice militaire malienne à ouvrir une
enquête voilà donc pour le contexte et
c'est dans ce contexte justement que
certaines publications met en doute la
version de l'om j'ai effectivement des
publications que leur on trouve
essentiellement sur les réseaux plutôt
adepte de la propagande anti français et
pro russe on notera par exemple dans
cette dans ce post facebook un ce
drapeau russe d'ailleurs ces
publications en fait elles vont ironisé
sur la présence de civils celles
évoquées par les ong en insistant sur la
présence importante d'armes on trouve
parfois des notes vocales en bambara la
langue officielle à malienne qui
justifie l'action de l'armée malienne
contre des civils jugés dangereux car
armée en cas rare mais en gros en clair
il n'y aurait pas pu avoir de civils
parce que les photos montrent des armes
et justement pour discréditer la version
des ong voici le type de photos que l'on
peut voir donc une présence importante
d'armes on le voit et ce commentaire par
exemple l'arsenal saisi sur les civils
de moura par les femmes à des forces
armées maniel c'est une image d'ailleurs
sur laquelle un désintérêt nos
internautes à interpeller la rédaction
de france 24 pour s'interroger harry
s'interrogeaient sur l'authenticité du
cliché bien une rapide recherche d'image
inversée via le moteur russe yandex nous
ramène sur des sites nigérians dont
celui ci on est en fait en avril 2020 il
y a deux ans donc le 4 plus précisément
il s'agit bien d'une saisie d'armes mais
par l'armée tchadienne et on apprendra
qu'il s'agit de l'opération colère de
boa m'a mené contre boko haram
conjointement par l'armée tchadienne et
nigérianes et quid de la deuxième photo
est bien la deuxième photo là encore on
ironise sur vous voyez sur un supposé
massacres de civils dans cette
publication facebook jugez vous-même
voici les populations aux mains nues de
moura il manque une lette là les
observateurs de france 24 ont utilisé
google dance pourquoi parce que en fait
la photo que vous avez vu elle a été
rogné à les plus petites que l'original
ça peut paraître un détail mais ça rend
la recherche d'image inversée beaucoup
plus difficile qu'avec les outils
classiques que nous dit google l'aisne
c'est bien il met en évidence ce tweet
d'un compte twitter qui analyse la
situation sécuritaire dans le liptako
gourou gourma pardon c'est à cheval
entre le niger le mali et le burkina
faso et vous voyez que nous dit ce tweet
ce 10 juin 2021 une équipe de
détachement de gendarmerie de harbin da
était accroché par des hommes armés et
de nous donner le bilan arminda sait où
c'est ici sur ce point rouge c'est au
burkina faso à proximité du mahdi certes
mais pas au mali et si on a filmé la
recherche cette fois sur facebook à la
seule année 2000 21 en ajoutant les mots
arts binda et attaquer bien on retrouve
plusieurs publications comme celle ci
qui atteste effectivement de cette
version et qui donne d'autres photos du
lieu comme ici et on retrouve par
exemple vous voyez ce sac de riz jaune
ou encore cette sorte de fait tout et
même un petit peu plus loin le sac ici
la pochette d'une marque que je ne
citerai pas qui commence par un f donc
si comme cet internaute vous avez repéré
des photos présentées comme étant prises
à mucha ou même de manière générale si
vous douté de l'authenticité de la deux
une image et bien vous n'hésitez pas à
nous envoyer un message c'est sur le
compte twitter des observateurs et
d'infos intox merci anthony st léger
info ou intox c'est terminé on se
retrouve dans trois minutes pour un
nouveau journal dans paris direct reste
avec nous